all right let's jump into this first
story The outrage following Ron
desantis's ban on sex change surgery for
kids AP news reports parents of
transgender kids seek to block DeSantis
ban on gender affirming care for minors
the first thing I want to say about this
is It's always language they never tell
you the truth this is what got me and
got me in trouble apparently with one of
our guests who's going to come on the
culture War podcast and then did not is
that
I'm not here to play games for the left
or the right but that means you're
basically going to be aligned with the
right what I mean by that is
we've got an editorial team over at uh
timcast.com we write news and one of the
Articles we were writing something came
up having to do with pro-choice and
pro-life and I was reading this and I
got kind of frustrated because there was
some quote from some activist and I said
I'm confused as to what they're trying
to say uh so I said I don't think we
should say pro-choice or pro-life those
are political terms if they're
protesting to ban abortion we should say
protesting in in opposition to abortion
or protesting in support of abortion so
we can just say anti or pro-abortion and
everybody agreed like that that's a fair
point remove the political terminology
from it be direct
that triggers the left they get very
very angry so in this instance you can
see right there in the headline gender
affirming care for minors that is a
leftist term that is an ideological term
to support their idea why is the AP
doing that so somebody at the AP said in
our style guide we are going to just use
the language of left-wing activists
here's what we say the right would call
it mutilation okay I don't I don't call
it that and and many conservatives are
like no that's what look I'm saying it
is a child sex change surgery and
medical intervention that's just a fact
statement that pisses the left off to no
end if you don't use their language
you're like that's it they come after
you whereas the right will just go okay
I guess the left is a the left has a
very significant authoritarian streak in
them right now in the U.S and in the
west you have to think like they think
if you talk like that's where the whole
gender uh gender you know using
someone's pronouns comes from like you
have to think of a trans Woman as a
woman trans women are women not trans
women are trans women
um they make a demand on your cognitive
Liberty this is as authoritarian as it
gets they're demanding that you think
like them and it bothers me that
liberals actual liberals in the U.S
are bad liberals and they don't see that
this is not authoritarian so we got this
tweet from Chris Hayes I love this one
he says the law to stand to sign in
Florida Banning care for Trans kids is
Despicable and a frontal assault on the
vaunted parental rights he and his
ideological cohort have been screaming
about for years in Florida you no longer
get to make Healthcare decisions for
your own child Rhonda sandus makes them
it doesn't matter what you think is best
for your kids Ron tells you this is the
weirdest thing but I I feel like as long
as you read the stories you can see
through the thin veneer the lies what is
he talking about you can't make Health
Care decisions for your kids no there's
there's a there's a medical uh the chief
medical officer or whatever they have
for the the Surgeon General in Florida
who makes these medical decisions on
what doctors you know basically
overseeing how the healthism is working
you've got low law the legislature Ronda
santis signed what the state legislature
presented to him they are they they're
playing a political game probably
because 2024 but it's all just so crazy
how they lie about all this stuff there
is no contradiction in saying a parent
has a right to decide what a child
learns and a parent does not have a
right to determine if their child should
be sterilized or not like at a certain
point the state intervenes to protect
children under Chris Hayes's argument he
thinks you should be allowed to
mercilessly beat your own children well
let's show you to what you think is best
for them right he's Pro snake handling
like like that's the thing the the state
should not step in and prevent snake
handling your CH you are chopping off
the genitals of children if children are
gender dysphoric you wait until after
puberty because gender dysphoria tends
to go away the idea that Chris Hayes is
saying is that Pete like the state
should not step in and say you can't
starve your you can't starve your
children the state should not step in
and say you must provide medical care to
your children like it's stepping in and
saying that it's okay for for the state
to or for parents to literally cut their
children allow their children to cut
their bodies up everyone knows that
tattoo like forever tattoos have been
off limits for anyone under 18 and there
was never a stink about it and now
because it's not oh God just the LGBT
Lobby and the ideology that comes along
with with trans with the LGBT
perspective
out it's like it's all about trying to
to shove the the idea down people's
throats I was gonna say it's not just
surgery it's the medication too it's the
it's the chemical uh puberty blockers
and uh and crosstex hormones which also
cause sterilization to the point where
uh even these high profile websites that
are advising on what they call gender
affirming care say you have to preserve
your reproductive material as these
these treat these treatments they call
it will tend to remove your ability to
reproduce I think too just people like
Chris Hayes they aren't used to seeing
Republicans wield power and fight back
especially on cultural issues because I
mean the GOP in my lifetime has
delivered you know tax cuts and endless
Wars and that's about it so I think you
know for the first time to see
conservatives wading into the cultural
issues and pushing back and fighting
this totally nut stuff is really
important and I think it's it shocks the
left because they're not used to it but
we need to do more of it because if you
don't have a culture you don't have a
country it's because when they say boo
when they call you racist or sexist or
homophobic then they get everyone on the
right to immediately cave to whatever
demands they have because they
understand that they do wield the power
of most of the journalists and all of
the all of that complex in this country
so if you have the power of 10 000
journalists who can use a bunch of
buzzwords and names to call you you
wield a lot of power to stop people from
proposing bills that they want to
propose from speaking out on social
media in the ways they want to and the
media does the same thing when they use
these terms like gender affirming care
which are to the uninitiated will read
it and aren't going to look into it any
further and all they're going to get
from that is evil right-wing guy does
evil right-wing thing because they're
bad and I think for the average person
who doesn't read the whole article who
only reads paragraph one who doesn't
look into what the actual meaning of
these terms are that wields a lot of
power because people don't look any
deeper I'm torn you know I am on the one
hand I'm concerned concerned about these
children and whether or not these
treatments actually are the right thing
to do because the science shows
desistance rates are very very high we
went over this with Lance from the serfs
around uh reaching up to 98 or something
like that so most kids go through
puberty and then they just stop
experiencing this and we've already seen
in Europe they've been abandoning these
procedures on the other hand
I think if Chris Hayes wants to
sterilize his children we shouldn't stop
him and I'm and you know it's funny
because I'm half kidding that the issue
here is I'm not a conservative Chris
Hayes comes out and says his children he
has the right to bring them to a doctor
and remove their ability to reproduce
and I'm kind of like well I suppose the
challenges do these children have rights
to not have their lives irreparably
harmed by the actions of their parents
answers yes of course just because a
doctor tells you to do it doesn't mean
it's the right thing to do but these
people are voting to to terminate the
lives of their children and take away
their and their children's ability to
reproduce and I'm kind of like
we're we're not in a position to assert
uh absolute authority over them to stop
them from doing it there has to be a
vote on it in Florida the vote has been
you can't do it Chris Isis is losing his
mind but if this guy then moves to a
state that allows it like California
it's like okay well you know the worst
case scenario in the end of all this is
the future is conservative
conservatives have a bunch of kids
liberals sterilize their kids the the it
it just seems like it doesn't matter in
the grand scale it matters to the
individual it matters to the rights it
matters what we think people should be
allowed to do to kids because those kids
are going to grow up they're going to be
very angry we've already seen it many d
transitioners but then I'm thinking
about
holistically the whole the whole world
and where we're going this is a small
blip in the history of the United States
that I think will cease to exist
relatively shortly I mean I definitely
agree with you that they're almost you
know self-selecting out of reproducing
and you know yeah and for us on the
right I mean that means more votes for
us right but also does it mean more
violence for us you look at people like
the Nashville shooter or the individual
who killed that woman in Arizona so
there is you know I think having
mentally ill people running around your
Society is not conducive to a society
that is safe and allows for you know
Community flourishing this is the Big
Challenge across the board though like
we see in San Francisco
we want to help people who are suffering
like this this is this is one of the
challenges humans face balancing helping
people with making sure that the crazy
people who are unwell aren't dragging
the whole system down you know they say
when you're asking on a plane you got to
put the mask on the person you gotta put
your own mask on before putting on the
mask of the person next to you so how
can we as United States keep doing the
opposite sacrificing our cities and our
economies for people who are not
contributing it's just breaking the
system then eventually we're going to be
left with empty cities and Barren
streets and no farms and no food and
people are going to wonder how it
happened
the there's I I don't know I it's it's
just so tiring to hear people like you
said lie like hearing Chris Chris Hayes
portraying things the way that he does
it's just it's exhausting and and
extremely frustrating because there's
there's people that have lives and they
go about their day and they don't have
the time to shove their face in Twitter
or read a bunch of queer Theory books or
you know it's and that's one of the
things that the left really relies on is
people living their lives and going
about their day and not knowing what
they're talking about every like we talk
on this show all the time about the fact
that there are that the the left has one
dictionary or that we use the the same
uh same lexicon but a different
dictionary the meanings of words change
and stuff that's intentional your
average person doesn't know that your
average person doesn't understand that
so when the left starts throwing around
jarging at them they feel like they're
like I don't know what any of this means
like ah just stop you know whatever you
say and it's such a manipulate it's so
manipulative and it's frustrating to see
so many people
constantly battering you with a message
and that that is is completely
fabricated I was talking to someone
recently when we were discussing the
idea that when you watch the news
depending on where you get your news
from you're living in a completely
different reality from the person next
to you if they get their news from a
different source and the language does a
lot of that in the same way you could be
having a conversation you buy you might
both know the word but you have your own
definitions for what that word means so
you end up with a completely different
conversation and you never actually get
to any type of understanding because you
can't get past the dialogue that's
spoken and I think that's also a problem
when we talk about you were talking
about whether you think that this is a
self-correcting problem that's why
they're so good at organizing and why
they're so good at recruiting Because
recruiting is how they grow because if
they're not having families if they're
not expanding through their own gene
pool they have to organize through
Community leadership they have to
organize through propaganda in the media
and they do that very very well and I
think in social media Tick Tock that is
how they influence the next generation
of people I don't think it will be as
easy as just something that cancels
itself out in a generation or two
because a lot of these people
conservatives included there was a thing
on Mother's Day where it said happy uh
Happy it was a Happy Mother's Day post
and it was a bunch of iPads
because kids are looking at their
parents are putting their a tablet in
front of them they're not watching what
they're looking at in the media and
that's right the kids younger and
younger are being influenced on websites
that are not protecting them uh yeah
what kid under the age of 13 was
wouldn't know to hit the I yes I am 13
Button on Tick Tock right so the kids I
don't think it's ever going to be as
simple as just it's going to be drown
out by the fact that they're not
reproducing it's something that you have
to culturally change whether that's
through Pro you know putting out your
own media that will be an alternative
source to them or the type of thing
where they need to do better about
making sure their kids aren't taking in
a bunch of stuff that they don't know
but then what do you do from there then
you go to the school system the school
system pushes on it too they really have
surrounded the culture in every way and
to me it sounds black pilled it's like
it's I don't think it's that simple I'm
not suggesting that we just sit back and
do nothing and then by having kids no
I'm saying it's all it's all
interconnected the less they have kids
and the more the right says we're not
bringing our kids to your schools you
will get a natural tendencies towards a
culture being developed by the right
which we're seeing across the board with
comic books and and cartoons as well as
parallel economies Jeremy's chocolate
and razors we got Casper coffee uh
Jeremy has uh Jeremy from the quartering
has coffee brand coffee a bunch of
companies popping up competing with the
establishment that is falling apart I
look at all of these in the big picture
and I'm just like over a long enough
period of time the future seems obvious
right I just I just feel like for me at
this at this point I'm like
I'm gonna invest in one of these
companies because it seems inevitable
sure there's a bunch of variables who
knows what'll change but I don't see how
you reverse course and Salvage the left
you've got decaying media organizations
they're going out of business CNN's
ratings have dropped below Newsmax
BuzzFeed news is gone Vice is isn't
bankruptcy all of these companies
they're they're losing clicks they're
losing followers they're freaking out
they're fleeing Twitter their influence
is crumbling then they're sterilizing
and aborting their own children
conservatives are pulling their kids out
of these schools their influence is
going to be gone in 10 years then you
add them to the fact they're not having
kids give it 20 or 30 years and you're
going to have two new generations
entering the cultural space who have not
been influenced by their by their media
because their media is ceasing to exist
Disney just announced they're going to
be moving a whole bunch of their
products over was it from from Hulu to
Disney plus yeah they're gonna bundle
everything so that you can get
everything but that means they're
they're also locking things up they also
got rid of a bunch of the like Willow
and the really bad stuff that came out
that they took like 50 or 60 things off
Disney plus because it's literally just
taking up server space and nobody's
watching any of it so but I just think
all of those things together their
predict a conservative future
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the timcast IRL podcast
and there's a massive library to check
out so again go to timcast.com or tune
in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there